hay muchos compuestos orgánicos que son
poco solubles en agua y el cloruro de
plomo es uno de esos compuestos iónicos
digamos que añadimos 10 gramos de
cloruro de plomo a 50 mililitros de agua
a una temperatura de 25 grados celsius y
digamos que solo 0.22 gramos del cloruro
de plomo se disuelven la mayor parte del
cloruro de plomo no está disuelto y
podemos mostrar eso en nuestro vaso de
precipitado por aquí digamos que esto
representa nuestro cloruro de plomo que
no está disuelto este es nuestro sólido
en nuestro vaso de precipitado una
porción del cloruro de plomo si se
disuelve una pequeña porción solo punto
22 gramos vamos a tener algunos iones en
solución tendremos iones
dos más en nuestra solución tv2 más
uniones de cloruro cl - esta es sólo una
pequeña representación de lo que está
sucediendo ahora tenemos una solución
saturada de cloruro de plomo tenemos una
sub
blue
acción
tú
así que tenemos iones en solución y
tenemos una cantidad grande de cloruro
de plomo no disuelto en el inciso a
nos piden calcular la solubilidad del
cloruro de plomo en agua a 25 grados
celsius primero encontrarás la
solubilidad en gramos por litro en
gramos por litro punto 22 gramos se
disuelven 0.22 gramos se disuelven en 50
mililitros de agua movemos nuestro punto
decimal 123 lugares eso nos da punto 0 5
litros
esto es punto 0 5 litros punto 22
dividido entre 0.05 es 4.4 gramos por
litro
esa es la solubilidad y la solubilidad
es el número de gramos de soluto en un
litro de una solución saturada si tienes
un litro de agua
sólo puedes disolver aproximadamente 4.4
gramos de cloruro de plomo en ese litro
de solución esa es la razón por la cual
este es un compuesto iónico poco soluble
una pequeña cantidad se disuelve
podemos encontrar la solubilidad también
en moles por litro la cual será la
solubilidad molar
sabemos que hay 0.22 gramos aquí para
encontrar a los moles tenemos que saber
la masa molar para el cloruro de plomo
tenemos al plomo con una masa molar de
200 7.2 tenemos 207
punto 2 a eso le tenemos que sumar dos
veces 35.45 porque tenemos dos claros
pvc l 2
35.45
dos veces 35.45 70.9 si sumamos eso a
doscientos 7.2 obtenemos 278 punto 12
por mol
esa es la masa molar del pvc l 2 si
dividimos los gramos entre los gramos
por mol dividimos a los gramos entre 270
y 8.1 gramos por mol
nuestros gramos se cancela
obtenemos gramos / gramos sobre mol así
que esto nos dirá cuántos moles
y ahora saquemos la calculadora y
hagamos esto tenemos 0.22 gramos
divididos entre 270 y 8.1 y eso nos da
punto 000 79 moles si redondeo eso
obtendremos punto 0 0 0 79 moles
queremos encontrar la solubilidad molar
así que tenemos que dividir moles entre
litros y ya vimos que tenemos 0.05
litros tenemos que dividir esto entre
0.05 litros
continuaremos utilizando un número
redondeado aquí
tenemos 0.00 0.79 dividido entre 0.05
nos da una sola bilidad molar de 0.01 58
lo que redondear hemos a 0.0 16 esto es
igual a 0.016
esto será molar
goles sobre litros es la polaridad esto
es la solubilidad molar del cloruro de
plomo en agua a 25 grados celsius tienes
que asegurarte de especificar la
temperatura porque obviamente si cambias
la temperatura cambias cuánto se puede
disolver en el agua esos son los
conceptos de solubilidad y solubilidad
molar ahora en el inciso b nos piden
calcular la constante del producto de
solubilidad kps a 25 grados celsius para
el cloruro de plomo kps es sólo una
constante de equilibrio pensemos en el
equilibrio de solubilidad pensemos en
esta imagen de aquí arriba
tenemos una solución saturada de cloruro
de plomo y nuestra solución está en
contacto con nuestro soluto de cloruro
de plomo aquí
y en equilibrio la proporción de
disolución es igual a la proporción de
precipitación la proporción en la que el
sólido se transforma en guiones es igual
que en la que los iones se convierten de
nuevo en un sólido continuamos
representando eso a tus p bcl2 el
cloruro de plomo es nuestro sólido y
nuestros iones son pp2 más en solución y
cl - necesitamos balancear esto
necesitamos 12 aquí antes de nuestro año
cloruro y todo lo demás tendrá un 1
si intentamos encontrar nuestra
constante de equilibrio kps necesitamos
empezar con una tabla y ce o ice por su
nombre en inglés empezaremos con la
concentración inicial luego pensamos en
el cambio y después encontraremos la
concentración de equilibrio pretendamos
que nada se ha disuelto aun pensemos que
no hemos hecho nuestra solución nuestra
solución saturada nuestras
concentraciones iniciales serían cero
para nuestros productos después tenemos
que pensar en cuánto de nuestro cloruro
de plomo se disuelve hicimos eso en el
inciso a cero puntos 0 0 079 moles de
cloruro de plomo se disuelven en el agua
y nuestra solubilidad molar era entonces
0.016 molar esa es la concentración de
cloruro de plomo que perderemos aquí
perderemos 0.016 molar que es la
concentración del cloruro de plomo y
supondremos que todo el cloruro de plomo
que se disolvió se disocia completamente
en iones así que por cada molde cloruro
de plomo que se disuelve obtenemos un
molde de plomo 2 + en solución
para perder 0.016 para la concentración
de cloruro de plomo o ganar' 0.016 para
la concentración de plomo 2 + y para el
año
oruro esta vez nuestro cambio fue de 1 a
2 tenemos que multiplicar este número
por 2
0.016 x 2 es igual a 0.03 2 estamos
ganando 0.03 2 molar
para la concentración de los año nes de
cloruro cuando el pp cl 2 que es soluble
en agua se disuelve por lo tanto en
equilibrio debemos de tener una
concentración de iones de plomo 2 + d
0.016 molar
y nuestra concentración de añón es de
cloruro deberá de ser de 0.0 32 molar y
ahora estamos listos para escribir
nuestra expresión de equilibrio
escribimos acá y como esta es una
constante de equilibrio escribiremos acá
ps kps es igual a recuerda que tenemos
la concentración de productos sobre
reactivos y para esto también debemos de
pensar en los coeficientes pensemos en
nuestros productos primero
bebé todos más tenemos la concentración
de tv2 más y vamos a elevar la
concentración a la potencia del
coeficiente aquí nuestro coeficiente es
un 1 así que vamos a elevar el
coeficiente a la primera potencia y
vamos a multiplicar esto por la
concentración de los anones de cloruro
cl - y luego vamos a elevar la
concentración a la potencia del
coeficiente aquí nuestro coeficiente es
un 2 así que vamos a elevar esto a la
segunda potencia todo esto es acerca de
la concentración de tus reactivos pero
aquí tenemos un sólido puro y recuerda
que dejamos fuera los líquidos puros y
sólidos puros de expresiones de
equilibrio
esta es nuestra expresión de equilibrio
la constante del producto de solubilidad
kps es igual a la concentración de los
iones de plomo 2 más a la primera
potencia por la concentración de la
unión cloruro a la segunda potencia
ahora podemos resolver para acá ps
porque sabemos la concentración de
equilibrio de nuestros iones podemos
sustituir con estos números era 0.016
para plomo 2 + y era 0.03 2 para hacerle
menos así que ahora podemos obtener el
valor de k de s kps es igual a 0.01 6 a
la primera potencia x
pero puntos 0.32 a la segunda potencia
podemos sacar la calculadora y hacer
esto punto 0 3 2 al cuadrado por 0.016
nos da 1.6 por ea la menos 5 esto es
igual a 1.6 por 10 a la menos 5 esa es
la constante del producto de solubilidad
kps del cloruro de plomo a 25 grados
celsius debería decir que he visto
diferentes valores de cape s para el
cloruro de plomo a esta temperatura así
que podrías ver una diferente si estás
viendo un libro de texto distinto pero
para mí eso no es lo importante para mí
lo importante es el entender cómo
calcularla kps escribiendo una expresión
de equilibrio y pensar en la
concentración de equilibrio de tus
productos de tus iones
y finalmente sólo hablemos de qué
sucedería si intentamos disolver 100
gramos en lugar de nuestros 10 gramos de
cloruro de plomo en el mismo volumen de
agua y a la misma temperatura así que
vayamos al inicio intentamos hacer 100
gramos en lugar de 10 esta vez volvemos
hasta acá arriba en lugar de 10 hablemos
de 100 a un solo 0.22 gramos se
disolverán en nuestros 50 mililitros de
agua tendremos una cantidad mayor de
cloruro de plomo no disuelto pero ya que
aún sólo podemos disolver 0.22 gramos la
solubilidad molar permanecerá igual y si
la solubilidad molar se queda igual
eso significa que nuestras
concentraciones en equilibrio se
quedarán igual y entonces la cape s
tiene exactamente el mismo valor y
entonces ojalá entiendas que es la
concentración del pvc l2 que se disuelve
la que determina tu kps no es la parte
que no se disuelve